[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD MIRO: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for
coming to our talk.
This is MLAI225,
Machine Learning
with TensorFlow and
PyTorch on Apache Hadoop
using Cloud Dataproc.
So I'm Brad Miro.
I'm a developer programs
engineer on Google Cloud.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Hi.
I'm Gonzalo Gasca.
I'm also developer
programs engineering cloud.
BRAD MIRO: So this
is Thursday morning.
You've probably seen this
slide 100 times already.
But we will be having Dory
accompanying this talk.
So if at any point during the
talk you have any questions,
feel free to just go
into the Dory on the app,
ask the questions.
And then we'll be going
through them at the end
and getting you the information
that you're looking for.
So what we're going
to discuss today--
we will start by
discussing machine learning
on Apache Hadoop generally.
We'll then discuss
Cloud Dataproc,
which is Google Cloud
Platform's managed Apache Hadoop
and Apache Spark service.
We'll then discuss
distributed machine learning,
some strategies for doing
that-- how you can actually
solve this problem currently.
And then we'll show you a
demo of running TensorFlow
and PyTorch on Cloud Dataproc.
So let's just dive
right into it.
But before we do
that, I just want
to survey the room very briefly.
Who here uses Apache
Hadoop on a regular basis?
Just a quick show of hands.
Awesome.
What about, who writes
machine learning algorithms
on a regular basis?
Just another quick
show of hands.
A few more hands.
And lastly, who uses
TensorFlow and/or
PyTorch on a regular basis?
Awesome.
Cool.
So we'll just start with
a bit of a survey of what
the Hadoop and machine
learning ecosystems look like.
Starting on the left,
in the Hadoop ecosystem,
you have your Apache Hive,
your Apache Pig, your Presto.
Those are for, of course,
querying Hadoop for your data.
And then you have Apache
Spark for running ETL jobs
and loading your
data into memory.
And, of course, the
rich ecosystem that
comes with Apache
Spark, specifically.
On the right side,
on the machine
learning side of
the diagram, you
have your packages such as
XGBoost and Scikit-learn.
And then, of course, in
the deep learning circle,
deep learning being a
subset of machine learning,
we have TensorFlow,
PyTorch, and Keras.
If we look at the intersection
of the two sides of the Venn
diagram, you'll notice that
we have Spark MLlib, which
is very similar to Scikit-learn,
for those of you who
may be familiar with that,
for running machine learning
models on Hadoop.
But noticeably, there's
nothing in this section
here for doing
TensorFlow or PyTorch.
So let's discuss
how to get there.
But why should you
care, of course?
So you may already have
an Apache Hadoop cluster.
And you may have pre-existing
investments there.
And instead of spinning
up new infrastructure,
you may just want to run
your jobs there and see
what some potential
models may look like.
You also may have existing
workflows for loading data
into and out of Hadoop.
And of course, if you have
all of your machine learning
processing running
on Apache Hadoop,
you don't have to worry
about the workflows changing.
And then you're able to
leverage them that way.
And then, of course,
being Apache Hadoop,
you are in the world of
distributed processing.
So, of course, you can
leverage that here, as well.
So TensorFlow and PyTorch--
we're just going to
go over these briefly,
what they are, as
they're mentioned
in the title, of course.
And we're going to
talk about them today.
So TensorFlow being an
open-source machine learning
framework that is
developed by Google,
it has access to distributed
machine learning.
So it is built into
the framework itself.
And there's ways
that you can do that.
It has a very rich
ecosystem of packages,
such as TensorFlow
Extended, for building
end-to-end machine
learning pipelines
as well as TensorBoard, which
is a nice UI for actually seeing
your models as it's training.
And you can set the metrics
on there that you want to see,
including accuracy or loss.
TensorFlow also utilizes
Keras as its high-level API.
For those of you who
have used Keras before,
you know how user-friendly it
is and how, in my opinion, fun
it is to use.
So, of course, that is
built right into TensorFlow.
And TensorFlow is also perfectly
suited for both production
and research.
So for all of your needs,
you can utilize TensorFlow.
I just want to do
a quick shout out
that TensorFlow 2.0
alpha was just released.
So if you're interested in
learning more about that,
check out TensorFlow.org.
And you can get started playing
around with the 2.0 version.
And then, of course, we're gong
to talk about PyTorch, too.
PyTorch is an open-source
machine learning framework
that was developed by Facebook.
PyTorch also supports
distributed machine
learning natively.
So you have access to run those
distributed jobs using PyTorch.
PyTorch has built-in
model layers.
So there's classes for
things such as an RNN
layer or a convolutional
neural network layer.
So you have access to those
just right out of the box.
And then, of course,
PyTorch is also
perfectly suited for
production and/or research,
depending on your needs.
So now that we've
discussed machine learning
on Apache Hadoop, let's
discuss Apache Hadoop
as it pertains to
Google Cloud Platform.
And so our solution to a
managed Apache Hadoop service
is Cloud Dataproc.
And so what is Cloud Dataproc?
It contains managed clusters for
Apache Hadoop and Apache Spark.
Cloud Dataproc
allows you to deploy
clusters in 90 seconds or less
on average for very quick up
times.
When you're using
Cloud Dataproc,
you only pay for the time
that your queries are running,
also known as compute time.
It's perfectly suited
to be configurable
with open-source solutions.
So, of course, we
have Apache Hadoop.
We have Apache Spark.
We have Apache Pig,
Apache Hive, as well as
what we call optical
components, which
are some of your favorite
open-source data science
libraries that you can
include with your cluster
when you spin it up.
So that includes things such
as Anaconda, Jupyter, Zeppelin,
Presto.
And there's a whole
long list of them
that you can find
on our website.
And Cloud Dataproc has
seamless integration
with a lot of GCP services,
including BigQuery and Google
Cloud Storage Connector.
Cloud Composer also has a
Cloud Dataproc operator,
which makes spinning your
cluster up and down using Cloud
Composer super easy to do.
And then Cloud Dataproc also
has the auto-scaling feature
that is currently in beta.
And autoscaling's a
really nice feature.
We're going to talk a
little bit more about it
later in the session.
But the idea behind it is that
as the pressure on your cluster
increases or decreases,
Cloud Dataproc can actually
add or remove workers without
you having to manually go
in and add them yourself.
You can do that, of
course, but this feature
allows you to not
have to do that.
And so we'll just
discuss a little bit more
about the architecture
behind Dataproc.
This will be fairly high
level, but we'll just
give you a little bit
more of an insight.
So starting on
the left tier, you
can see that we
have your networking
and your IEM layers like
you would for any other GCP
service in our stack.
Next, you have the
Cloud Dataproc API.
And so this is really
awesome for actually
interfacing with your cluster.
You have the ability to
interact with the cluster also
via the UI.
But using the cloud
console commands,
you can interact
with your cluster.
You also have access
to the jobs API,
which allows you to preset what
type of job you're submitting.
So, for instance, if
you're submitting,
let's say, a PySpark
job to Cloud Dataproc,
you can set that when
you submit the command.
And then, this
way, Cloud Dataproc
will preconfigure the
runtime environment for you.
And then you also have access
to your Hadoop and Spark
operations via the Dataproc API.
So you have access to all of
those tools through the API.
And then, of course,
within the cluster itself--
so you have your Cloud
Dataproc open source image.
And so, as I mentioned
earlier, that
can include your Apache
Spark, your Apache Hadoop,
Apache Hive, Apache Pig.
And then there's the
optional components
that I was mentioning, as well.
So here, we have Jupyter,
Zeppelin, and Presto mentioned.
But there's a whole list of
them, as I mentioned earlier.
You can do Anaconda.
You can do RStudio.
There's a whole bunch of them.
And then, of course, being
a Hadoop cluster, of course,
you can write out to either
HDFS or to Google Cloud Storage.
So now that we've
discussed machine learning
on Apache Hadoop and
Google Cloud Platform's
solution to having an
Apache Hadoop service,
we're going to talk about
distributed machine learning
right now.
But I think Gonzalo has
something to say about it.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Perfect.
Thanks, Brad.
So what is distributed
machine learning?
Quite important in
the context of Hadoop.
If you're a machine learning
engineer, a data scientist,
or you've been experimenting
with deep learning models,
you probably know
when you are training
large machine learning models,
they take a very long time.
So some of those may
take a couple of hours.
Some of those take days.
And they are very large models
that may take even weeks
to complete training.
So the first application for
distributed machine learning
is try to reduce
this training time.
Another application for
distributed machine learning
will be, try to run
experiments in parallel.
So, for example, if you are
doing hyperparameter searching,
you can run multiple
modes simultaneously
so you can save some time.
So let's take a look at how
this journey looks like.
So normally, when you're
still experimenting
with your deep
learning models, you
can use your local computer or
a virtual machine in the clouds.
And you start with
a multicore CPU.
That might be OK for various
small training models.
But if you really want to
take advantage and reduce
the training time, you
can use accelerators.
An accelerator could be
a TPU, a GPU, or an FPGA.
For this talk, I'm only
going to be referring
to accelerators as GPUs.
So what do you do?
You install the drivers.
You attach your device.
And if you're using frameworks
like TensorFlow or PyTorch,
you need very little
or no code modification
to start training your models.
If you can attach one GPU,
why not to attach more GPUs?
Again, you attach more GPUs.
You start doing your training.
And if you're using a
framework like TensorFlow,
there's something
new in TensorFlow
which is called
distribution strategies.
So with distribution strategies,
the goal of the TensorFlow API
is like, don't care too
much about the underlying
infrastructure.
So you just define what is
your underlying architecture.
So for example, if you're
running a single node,
you might use define,
oh, I have two GPUs.
So you can continue adding
GPUs into your single node.
But at some point, you're
going to hit some hardware
limitations.
And from an architectural
perspective,
instead of scaling up, you
want to scale horizontally.
So the next obvious
step is going
multi-node, multiple GPUs.
Well, multiple nodes
and multiple GPUs
might help you reduce
your training time.
In reality, you need to
consider other factors.
For example, how is
the communication
between the devices
and network overhead
between those multiple nodes?
So when we talk about
distributed machine learning,
there are two main
paradigms that we always
need to talk about.
So the first paradigm is
called data parallelism.
So with data
parallelism, you normally
have your neural network or your
model and you store it locally.
And then you start
training your model
with different slices of data.
So this could be
synchronous or asynchronous.
If it's asynchronous, which
is like the traditional way
of doing TensorFlow,
you normally
train your model
different slices of data.
And the workers might be
doing the heavy lifting.
For example, they will be
computing all the gradients.
And your parameter
server or another server
might be just doing the
averaging of those gradients.
That would be like
the asynchronous, way.
And there are new techniques,
like new distribution
strategies.
For example, a
mirroring strategy,
which actually is
called synchronous,
where all the devices compute
the gradients locally.
And they communicate those
directly or indirectly
to others.
They will be updating the
model only when it's required.
But sometimes, your
model is quite large,
that you actually cannot
feed it into one device.
So if you think of
a neural network,
you might need to split
these different layers
into multiple devices.
So TensorFlow allows
you to execute
different parts of the
graph in different devices.
This is called
model parallelism.
So an example of
these models would be
wide and deep neural networks.
And one example is the Google
neural machine translation
model.
That's a very large model.
So this slide is taken from
the TensorFlow web page.
This is a training model
that the TensorFlow team did.
So basically, what
they did was, they
collected four different
models which are
very popular for benchmarking--
InceptionV3, VGG16,
ResNet-50 and 152.
And they trained them
with different GPUs--
one, two, four, and eight.
So what they actually
found is, the more
GPUs that we are
actually add, the faster
we can process those images.
So you can see there's
a linear growth based
on the number of
GPUs that we add.
And the faster we're actually
able to process those images,
the faster the training
is actually happening.
But what happens when
you go from research
or experimentation
to production?
There's more than training.
So you normally have a pipeline.
And I'm going to go through
a very simplified, probably
oversimplified machine
learning pipeline.
And you're going to start
with data preparation.
So think about feature
engineering or your regular ETL
process where you are
collecting your data,
you are selecting which
features you need.
And normally, in this
case, you don't need a GPU.
Probably, you are fine
with a CPU cluster.
If you think of the
Apache ecosystem,
you will be using Apache
Spark on this one.
Once you collect your data
and it's ready to be trained,
you have your
trained data now, you
move to a different stage,
which is the training data.
So we just agree that using
accelerators is a good option.
And you have access
to those devices.
In reality, if you work
with different departments
or you are running different
experiments in your company,
you probably need to be
considerate about how
you use these devices.
When you allocate a GPU, when
you allocate an accelerator,
you need to make sure that--
you need a resource manager.
It's not like I'm just going
to be configuring my TensorFlow
web page, my TensorFlow
work, and it's just
going to be working.
So once you move from training,
you go to the serving phase
where you can have
both CPU and GPUs.
So if you think of
serving, you would
use Kubernetes, maybe, some
Docker containers running
TensorFlow serving.
And you will be fine,
maybe, with CPU.
But if you really
want to increase
the speed for your inference,
you may want to add GPUs.
A good example of a GPU that
is designed only for inference
would be the Tesla
T4 from NVIDIA.
So we agreed that when
you use resources,
you need a resource manager.
And there's already applications
that solve this problem.
Think about YARN, think
about Mesos or Kubernetes.
But how do you
configure, actually,
TensorFlow to have
access to these devices?
In the classical way for
configuring TensorFlow,
you normally define
your cluster.
And you define the IP
address to some ports,
which are going to be
running your TensorFlow code.
You might define your workers,
your parameter servers.
Then you stop and you start
your servers based on your job.
But this is something data
scientists don't really
want to do, or this is very
focused on dev operations.
There's something
called tf.config,
which is an environmental
variable that is designed
to address this problem.
So a lot of a resource
managers, like Kubernetes,
supports this
environmental variable.
So basically, you define
a cluster specification
which you're only
going to be reading.
And then from there, you
can execute your code.
So we're going to go through
some of the list of products
that actually already
address this problem,
meaning resource allocation
and running distributed machine
learning workflows.
Who is familiar with
some of these products
like Kubeflow, AI Platform,
Horovod, TensorFlow on Spark
or Spark Deep Learning?
Anybody has used any of this?
Yeah.
Cool.
So one of the
things that we care
in the context of this talk is
that it's supported on YARN.
It runs on Hadoop.
So the first
product is Kubeflow.
So it's based on the
Kubernetes environment.
So this might not
be a good option.
The second one is AI Platform.
It's previously known as
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And we just changed the name.
And this is great for
model training, inference,
and model versioning.
But it is a hosted
solution by Google.
So you really don't care
about infrastructure.
So we just bring your
model and we handle
the infrastructure for you.
The other one is Horovod.
It's more like a library.
So Horovod's a library by Uber.
So Horovod, the problem
that we're trying to solve
is running distributed machine
learning on top of TensorFlow
to be able to speed
up the training time.
And it doesn't
really run on Hadoop.
It's more like a helper.
And then we have two
products, TensorFlow and Spark
from Yahoo, which was one of
the best of the first solutions
trying to address this problem.
So TensorFlow on Spark runs
on two different layers--
the Spark layer and
then the TensorFlow--
the TensorFlow layer, the Spark
layer, and the YARN layer.
From this, you rely on the Spark
to do the resource allocation.
And then you need to pass
that request to YARN.
So you need very little
code modification.
And it works great
for some workflows.
The other one is Spark Deep
Learning from Databricks.
So it follows the same paradigm.
And it integrates very
good with the ML flow
ecosystem from Databricks.
But one of the things that we
actually care is GPU support.
So when we think of
GPU supporting Hadoop,
if we are using--
there's something that
we need to mention.
So Hadoop version
3.1 is the version
that, in reality,
supports GPU allocation.
This means when
you are attaching
a GPU to your devices,
resource managing Hadoop,
it's somewhere that you
have a GPU connected.
And before Hadoop 3.1,
there's another workaround,
which is using node labels.
So basically, you tag your
servers that have a GPU
so when you run your
jobs, you basically
route that job to the service
that have GPU already.
But it's not native
support for GPU.
One of the problems
with this is that when
you're using TensorFlow
in Spark or Spark
Deep Learning is that
you have a layer on top,
which is the Spark.
So Spark also requires to be
able to be aware of the GPUs.
And there's already some
work in the Spark community.
I think the Spark people know
is going to be supporting this.
But there's still a year
open for this issue.
So that's why it's
important to, if we really
want to take advantage of the
GPU, have native YARN support.
So then in comes TonY.
What is TonY?
TonY is a project which
stands for TensorFlow on YARN,
although it also
supports PyTorch.
So the main functionality
for TonY is orchestrate,
distribute TensorFlow
or PyTorch jobs in YARN.
But it also supports
single jobs.
So you can bring
your single node job
and execute it on Hadoop.
It was developed by LinkedIn
and it was open source back
last summer.
So what are the important
things about TonY?
So TonY is going to be
supporting first-class jobs
from running Hadoop.
This means when you run a
TensorFlow job or PyTorch job,
it's going to be the same as
you were running on Spark job.
It just runs on the same level.
If you're really
invested in Hadoop
and know your
infrastructure but you
want to start experimenting
with deep learning,
we want you to minify your
infrastructure [INAUDIBLE]..
So your data scientists and
machine learning engineers
can start using the products.
So TonY allows you
to have a client--
and we're going to
go more into details.
You're going to have
a client that you're
going to be using to
execute your jobs.
And one of the
features from Tony
is that you can
request resources
in a very fine-grained manner.
This means if you have a
TensorFlow job or PyTorch,
you can request how much memory,
how many cores are you going
to be using, and how many GPUs.
And jobs require very
little parameters.
So normally, when you
execute a Python script,
you have a virtual environment
with all your libraries.
And you have your Python files.
So what other thing we need?
You need a configuration file.
So as little as three options.
You can actually execute a TonY
job over other possibilities.
And if you're running
long training jobs,
you want to make sure
that those jobs actually
complete successfully.
So when you launch
a TonY job, you
need to be able to verify that
all your workers are executing
correctly.
And if some of your
containers actually fail,
you need to be
able to restart it.
So let's take a look at
the TonY architecture.
The first thing, when you
want to run a TensorFlow job
or PyTorch job, that you
need to bring is your code.
So you bring your code.
And the second
thing is, you need
to bring your
virtual environment.
So the virtual environment is
going to be in a zip format
or compressed.
And finally, your configuration,
which is the resources that you
actually need.
So this configuration
is an XML file
that you can define when you
have CPU, how much memory you
require for each of the workers
and how many GPUs you need.
So those three things are the
first part of running a job.
Then you need the TonY client.
TonY client is a jar file
that is compiled using Gravel.
So TonY is built on Java.
So when you launch
TonY, when you're
going to be launching a TonY
job, you execute the job.
And it's going to
contact Hadoop YARN.
spin up a container.
So this is the application
master container.
So application
master container is
going to see what you
configure and negotiate
the resources with YARN.
So, for example, if you
negotiate three workers,
it's going to try to allocate
resources for those three
workers.
That's the second
element of TonY.
Then you have your
task executors.
So task executors is
actually your machine
learning code that is executing.
And those are based on the
resources that you requested.
So those are YARN containers.
So task executors is going to
be your machine learning code
that is actually executing.
So we have talked a lot
about different topics.
But do you think
it's time for a demo?
BRAD MIRO: I think it is.
I think we should show our
audience a little bit about how
to run TensorFlow on
Google Cloud Platform.
So I know we were
discussing before this talk
that you had actually set
up Cloud Dataproc cluster.
And do you mind telling us
how you may have done that?
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Sure.
Creating a Dataproc
cluster is very simple.
So the first thing
that you need to use
is, you can use the gcloud
command or you can use the UI.
If you're going to use
the gcloud command,
you just need to
define your cluster
name and the number of workers.
This will be your node
managers in Hadoop.
Then we can take advantage of
a feature called initialization
action, which are shell scripts
that are going to be executed
during cluster creation time.
In this case, we have
two, the TonY shell script
and the GPU drivers.
The TonY shell script,
what it's going to do
is, it's going to clone the
code from the GitHub repo.
And it's going to build
the YARN file for TonY.
In the official
shell script, we also
provide two samples,
one with TensorFlow
and one with PyTorch code,
that you can actually use.
In the second shell
script what we
do is, because we
want to use GPUs,
we need to install the drivers.
And we need to set
up a stack driver
service that is going to be
monitoring the GPU utilization.
In this case, we're going
to be using two GPUs.
So for each of
the workers, we're
going to be attaching
a Tesla V100 GPU.
And because we want to
run many, many jobs,
we want to enable
autoscaling policy.
BRAD MIRO: Awesome.
Well, thank you for
telling us that.
I think we should
now run some jobs.
So the floor is yours.
Could we switch to
the demo, please?
Thank you.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Perfect.
So we created a
cluster in advance.
This has the workers.
Let's go to the instances.
You can see here, there's
the master node and then
the two workers with--
each of these has a GPU.
So let's run some jobs.
I'm going to be running one
TensorFlow job to start.
BRAD MIRO: Wait.
You're only going to run one?
Hold on.
We have autoscaling enabled.
We can do more than one.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Maybe two?
BRAD MIRO: How about 10?
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: OK.
BRAD MIRO: And let's
do a PyTorch job, also,
for good measure.
Cool.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Perfect.
So I create a script that
is going to be launching
those TensorFlow jobs.
And let's take a
look at this script.
So I'm using the gcloud command
to run the TensorFlow code.
So in this case,
we're submitting
a Hadoop job in the cluster
that we just created.
The TonY client is
just a jar file.
So we define the jar file here.
And because it's a jar file, we
just need to define the class.
One feature for TonY
also not only allows
you to run Python code, but
you can also run notebooks
like [INAUDIBLE] notebooks.
Or you can even run
Docker Containers.
The only requirement is that
your Hadoop infrastructure
is ready for Docker.
So in this case, we are
actually running Python code.
So when we were
talking about how
TonY is minimalistic in
terms of executing code,
one of the things that, as you
can see, we tried to emulate
is, if you're a data
scientist, you normally
run a Python command like this.
You have a virtual environment.
You're leaving the
source directory.
And then you run Python
and your Python file.
And because this is
machine learning code,
you should be able to
pass some parameters.
So this is exactly what,
actually, TonY requires.
So here, you pass the
virtual environment.
This is your [INAUDIBLE]
You pass the Python executable.
And then your script.
In case you have more files, by
defining the source directory,
you should be able to get
all those dependencies.
BRAD MIRO: Gonzalo, what is
that mnist_distributed.py job?
What is that actually
going to be doing?
GONZALO GASCA MEZA:
So in this case, what
we're going to be
doing is, we're
going to run the Hello
World for machine learning,
but distributed, where we're
going to be using the mnist
data set.
So it's a convolutional network
for [INAUDIBLE] detection.
BRAD MIRO: Cool.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: And finally,
we have the configuration file.
Let me go back here.
Oops.
So this is how your TonY
configuration file looks like.
In this case, we're going to
be spinning up the workers.
This is the
requirements for memory.
We're going to be using
one parameter server.
This is a requirement for our
parameter server and one GPU.
So let's take a look
how this looks in YARN.
BRAD MIRO: Wait a minute.
I asked for a PyTorch job and
I haven't seen any PyTorch job.
So let's get some
PyTorch in here.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: So in
order to run this PyTorch job,
we're going to be
using the Dataproc API.
So Dataproc allows you
to submit Python code.
It's very similar unless
you do the gcloud command,
but from the API directly.
So what I'm doing is just
importing the Dataproc API.
I'm defining my project.
So in this case, you can see
my project ID, my region.
And this is a TonY client.
So it's a jar file.
So we talk about how
Dataproc, by default,
has the GCS connector.
So you can actually weed
out any configuration,
have access to
your gcloud bucket.
So this is like using the latest
TonY version, which is 0.3.1.
We define the class.
This is just a helper function.
And this is how it normally
looks in the gcloud command
that we just launched.
But we're going to do
it from the client.
So you define your job
controller, your arguments.
You create your Hadoop job.
And then you're going
to define which cluster
you're going to send this job.
And now, we just send the job.
Let's take a look at
Dataproc for all these jobs.
Let me go to the cluster
so it's slightly easier.
So here are our 10 jobs.
And this is just the PyTorch
job that we just created.
And you can see that one
job already completed.
We can use the monitoring tab.
And there's a lot
of memory being
used that is actually pending.
Do you think autoscaling
is going to work?
BRAD MIRO: Absolutely.
Can we just get the
slide back, please?
So let's just talk about
autoscaling really quickly
and how you can enable
that on the cluster.
So Gonzalo was showing
you before how here, we
have the autoscaling policy that
we've called autoscale_tony.
And what that actually
looks like is,
it's just a YAML file that
gets uploaded to Google Cloud.
Here, you can see that there's
only two top-level components.
We have the worker config
and the basic algorithm.
So we'll just discuss
what those are.
We'll start with
the worker config.
You'll see here that we
have two parameters set.
We have the min instances
and the max instances,
respectively, set to two and 10.
What this means is
that as autoscaling
is adding and removing
workers to the cluster,
it will always make sure that
the total number of workers
is within these two
numbers, inclusively.
So this will never have
less than two workers
and never more than 10.
And how does it actually
figure out how many workers
it should add?
So it uses the basic
algorithm for that.
And here, we've set
the time to check
to be two minutes, as we've
denoted by the cooldown period.
So every two minutes, it will
look at the available memory
and the pending memory.
And then it'll calculate how
many workers it should add.
And then, once it comes
up with that number,
it will then multiply it
by either the scale up
or the scale down
factor, depending
on how many workers it thinks
it should add and remove.
And so what this
number does is, it
gives you some more
fine-grained control
as to how quickly you
may want the cluster
to scale up or scale down.
In this case, we've
set these both
to 1.0, which means
that the cluster will
attempt to have as near-perfect
memory utilization as possible.
But in the event that you
don't care about that,
and if there's a spike
in your pending memory,
you don't necessarily need to
have a bunch of clusters added.
You can scale this number down
to, let's say, 0.5 or 0.1.
Just completely dependent on
whatever your use case is.
So you have the option there.
And then, last but not least, we
have the graceful decommission
timeout.
And what this value does is, if
your cluster determines that it
should take down
some of the workers,
it will actually set, in this
case, a 15-minute lag to it
so that in case there's any
jobs that are currently running,
you wouldn't want the cluster
to just take the workers down
and have those jobs
disappear on you.
So just a small anecdote--
Gonzalo and I were recently
working on a project
where we were using
the autoscaling feature
and we had that happen to
us, where the jobs were just
failing.
And we never configured this.
So it was just-- or I believe
we had set this to 0 minutes.
And then the jobs
were just failing.
So we added this, and of
course, that perfectly
solved our problem.
So that's autoscaling.
Let's see, maybe, do we
have any more workers?
We started with two.
Hopefully there's more than two.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA:
Let's take a look.
Can we go back to the demo?
Perfect.
So let me maximize this.
So this is the YARN UI.
You can see that the
scaler was very busy.
And some of the
jobs still running.
And other are still waiting
to get the resources.
BRAD MIRO: And I see
that PyTorch job.
Good.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Yeah.
This is when we were saying
the application type.
TonY is a native of YARN.
So each of these jobs
requests like 12 gigabytes
of RAM, two workers,
4 gigabytes each,
plus the parameter server--
2.
Plus the application
container, which is another 2.
That's 12 total.
So you can also monitor the
utilization, here, in Dataproc.
But looks like
something is happening.
Let's take a look.
You can see here how the
cluster has been scaling up,
which is very good.
BRAD MIRO: I see
there's three workers.
That's great.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Yeah.
And you can see
here this, as well.
BRAD MIRO: Perfect.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: But let's
see how the jobs are doing.
Good.
So what I'm going to do is just
make sure my jobs are actually
completed correctly.
So you can pick any of the
jobs and see the configuration.
And these are the
exact parameters
that we passed when
we created the job.
And we created one
job identifier just
for the sake of having an ID.
And you can see here all
of our task parameters.
So we are training the
model with 750 steps.
So I'm going to be launching
TensorBoard to see that.
This is just a script that
launches TensorBoard locally.
But the data, as you guys
saw in the training--
let me go back here.
The data actually lives in
your gcloud storage bucket.
And we didn't need to configure
anything-- just out of the box.
So let's see if
TensorBoard is running.
Oh, good.
BRAD MIRO: Look at that.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: So this
was trained for 750 steps.
And as you can see,
the more steps that
are actually executing, the
accuracy keeps increasing.
And the cross-entropy laws,
it's reducing, as well.
This is a convolutional network.
So you can see here all
the graph and the nodes
that are connected.
BRAD MIRO: Looks like something
cool to point out here
is that using TonY
on Apache Hadoop,
you have access to the full
suite of TensorBoard features,
as Gonzalo was showing you.
So I think that that's a
really nice feature to have,
TensorBoard being as useful
as it is and as helpful
as it is for
training your models.
And it looks like our jobs
are doing pretty well.
GONZALO GASCA MEZA: Yep.
BRAD MIRO: Cool.
So I think, in the interest
of time, we'll just wrap up.
But you'll see that we have
five of them finishing.
And if we were to give
this more time, of course,
these will continue to run.
If we can just go back
to the slides, please.
Awesome.
So we'll just close
out and just quickly
recap what we discussed
today and what we showed you.
So we started off by
discussing machine learning
on Apache Hadoop and
what that looks like,
what the current
landscape for that is.
We then discussed and
introduced Cloud Dataproc to you
as a Google Cloud Platform
manage Apache Hadoop and Apache
Spark service.
We then discussed
distributed machine learning
and some of the options and
strategies for doing that.
And then, of course, we
introduced TonY to you
and showed you a demo of how
you can get started using TonY.
And we used Cloud Dataproc as
our means to show you that.
So if you're interested in
learning more about this,
here's the link for the
actual TonY repo itself.
It's github.com/linkedin/TonY,
T-O-N-Y. Also,
if you have any questions,
feel free to add your questions
to the Stack Overflow
under the #tony tag.
And we'll be happy
to answer you.
And then, for the code
that we showed today,
we're actually to be
sharing that over Twitter
in the next couple of days.
So feel free to
follow us on Twitter.
Gonzalo @Gogasca, and
myself @bradmiro, Brad Miro.
And so thank you,
everyone, for coming.
Just a quick shout
out to the-- we
want to just thank
the Cloud Dataproc
team, the LinkedIn team,
as well as the producers
in the room, and also
all of our friends,
who were super helpful
in helping us out
with this presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]